c'était le secret de ma vie je veux
partager avec jésus et j'ai dû le
partage et peut-être avec mon petit
frère et avec un ami je voulais être
prêtre
[Musique]
je pense qu'à 80% c'est la famille qui
est le lieu d'éclosion de la vocation je
serai pas comment mais vers 6-7 ans
c'était le secret de ma vie je le
partager avec eux jésus et j'ai dû le
partage est peut-être un peu mon petit
frère et avec un ami je voulais être
prêtre
ironie c'est qu'à 15 ans j'ai pensé plus
du tout et la question du de l'appel
était devenu trop compliqué et qu'elle
est revenue lors d'un pèlerinage à
chartres à 23 ans après tout hein pas
mal de méandres comme une évidence je
dirais comme une évidence que le christ
ne m'avait jamais abandonné
on a beaucoup définit le prêtre
peut-être dans les années 60 comme par
l'engagement alors le prêtre était un
peu un assistant social quelque part ça
ça touche pas le coeur du ministère du
prêtre
le prêtre c'est d'abord un mystère le
prêtre c'est le représentant du christ
c'est celui qui agit dans les sacrements
comme on dit une personne à christie
jésus avait besoin demain pour continuer
son ministère
déjà il faut se lever le matin et puis
la première chose c'est la prière donc
en fait c'est d'abord de prendre une
heure d'oraison et puis ça avec les
prêtres le jour de leur ordination
diaconale ont pris l'engagement de prier
tous les jours la liturgie des heures
donc c'est à dire les cinq offices de la
journée que les moines pris dans le
coeur mais nous on est pris avec notre
petit bréviaire on sur notre application
iphone ensuite là j'arrive à l'église et
puis la matinée elle est essentiellement
pendant au moins deux heures consacrées
à l'ouverture du courrier
vous êtes curé de paroisse et bas il va
falloir réparer la toiture et puis
beaucoup de temps dans la journée c'est
des rendez vous quatre cinq six rendez
vous d'une heure ou vraiment les gens
nous ouvrent leur vie les gens seraient
vraiment surpris de voir tout ce qu'on
voit ça et tout ce que la confiance qui
nous est faite
je vais peut-être vous surprendre je
sais beaucoup de mariages je célèbre
beaucoup de baptême mais là où je me
sens le plus à ma place et où il ya une
vraie joie spirituelle c'est
l'accompagnement en fin de vie
la célébration des obsèques c'est de
pouvoir aider les gens à traverser cette
étape est vraiment à l'illuminé
personnellement j'ai une figure qui pour
moi est une figure de prêtres c'est
celle de maximilien kolbe savez ce
prêtre qui a pris la place dans le camp
d'auschwitz d'un père de famille qui
étaient condamnés à mourir dans le
bunker de la fin ils savaient qu'ils
étaient là pour montrer le chemin du
ciel dont il s'est laissé enfermé entre
quatre murs
au milieu de quelque chose de terrible
de gens qui allaient mourir et qui
risquaient de mourir dans leur colère
dans leur révolte et et il leur a ouvert
à chacun le chemin du ciel
il les a recueillis lors dernier souffle
il les a aidés à faire la paix a
pardonné à ceux qui étaient autour de
etc
et je vous avoue que c'est une on voit
dieu on voit dieu réellement présents
dans ces moments là
moi je peux vous dire c'est pas
prêtre aujourd'hui c'est passionnant
mais c'est pas facile j'étais même très
difficile en fait comme aumônier c'est
très dur de voir le regard que nous
renvoient la suspicion aujourd'hui avec
les scandales qui a pu avoir les
scandales sexuels ou les scandales
d'emprise
franchement si on m'avait dit avant
l'ordination ski il m'arriverait jeu
heureusement qu'on l'a pas dit qui a une
grasse d'ameublement mais je peux vous
dire deux choses les épreuves sont
infiniment supérieur à tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer avant mais la joie qu'on
reçoit la joie convient et je vous
promets que c'est pas une vrille et sait
pas c'est pas une manière de parler elle
dépasse tout ce que je ne pouvais
imaginer
c'est ma première année de sacerdoce
quand je suis arrivé dans un quartier un
peu plus difficile que celui dans lequel
je suis et ma voiture a été brûlée est
en réalité celui qui l'a brûlée qui
était un jeune de 13 ans j'ai demandé à
rencontrer
il se trouve que c'était une famille
très hâte et avec le père avait exigé
que son fils passe devant le juge pour
justifier de l'acte qu'il avait fait et
quand je suis arrivé dans la famille qui
m'accueillait pour qu'on en parle ils
ont été surpris de voir après être
arrivé un prêtre jeunes qui plus est et
j'ai vu ce jeune homme qui a 13 ans et
qui avait deux petits frères dont le
dernier petit frère qui est un qui était
un enfant trisomique est bon le début de
l'entretien a été un peu difficile parce
qu'il y avait clairement une réserve de
la part des parents en tout cas puis à
un moment j'ai dit aux garçons à l'aîné
l'a qui allait brûler une voiture je les
ai pris à part et lui dit si on a
quelque chose de commun il se trouve que
moi j'ai une soeur qui est porteuse de
handicap comme ça je suis dit tiens on
peut faire des bêtises pour pour se
faire remarquer moi aussi j'ai existe
hélas a transpercé le coeur des parents
et on s'est retrouvé à ce niveau là d un
homme qui n'avait pas la fois j'étais
même très engagé dans dans party
communisme ce bien est donc c'était un
peu don camillo et peppone pour ceux qui
connaissent un peu qu'ils se
retrouvaient et on avait une profonde
communion une rencontre très très
profonde
voilà c'est une des joies du ministère